I see an opportunity to generate reality
which is not limited to the physical law
that reality abide to nowadays all our
life we're in the cage of our body we
see things from our point of view we can
go wherever our body can get us and what
our senses can do and sadly we could see
things from someone else's point of view
we could extend our senses and as much
as it's life-changing for me it could be
even more life-changing for people that
currently has limitations in a
non-physical world then there's less
importance of what my physical ability
is you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
dr. al Oh feck is a senior researcher at
Microsoft Research and his work deals
mainly with well reality augmented and
virtual reality to be precise a serial
entrepreneur before he came to MSR dr.
effec knows a lot about the long nose of
innovation and what it takes to bring a
revolutionary new technology to a world
that's ready for it
on today's podcast dr. effect talks
about the unique challenges and
opportunities of augmented in virtual
reality from both a technical and social
perspective tells us why he believes AR
and VR have the potential to be truly
revolutionary particularly for people
with disabilities explains why while
we're doing pretty well in the virtual
worlds of sight and sound our sense of
virtual touch remains a bit more elusive
and reveals how if he and his colleagues
are wildly successful it won't be that
long before we're living in a whole new
world of extension expansion enhancement
and equality that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
a LFX
welcome to the podcast hi great to be
here you're a senior researcher at
Microsoft Research and your work is
centered around reality particularly as
we've talked about augmented reality and
virtual reality or AR and VR as I will
refer to them for the rest of the
podcast and even this idea of mixed
reality which we didn't talk too much
about before we get started let's
operationalize those terms right
obviously there's some overlap how would
you define the different kinds of
realities that you're working on from a
technical perspective and how are they
the same or different from each other so
I would say it's a continuum there's no
one point we sense the world by our
senses seeing hearing tasting smelling
and so on and going to augmented reality
or virtual it's a different levels of
intervening with those senses let's say
that right now I'm looking from my eye
and I see the reality but if I will in
part of my field of view right now put
something new there then this is what
people call augmented reality where you
see reality but there's something I know
is real that appears there if I continue
adding more and more content there I see
less and less of reality and eventually
when all my field of view is filled up
with new content this is what we call
virtual reality but those terms again
are just pointing on a continuum and the
same can go for audio and other senses
so if you're not experiencing anything
additional then it's real reality yes as
far as we can define that exactly
exactly that's a whole other podcast
let's talk about grand aspirations for a
second as we're getting started here
what is the big idea behind AR and VR
what are you trying to accomplish what
gets you up in the morning first
philosophically we understand the world
around us through the senses it's a
whole new world we could see how digital
not
physical things could change our reality
this is a whole new concept up til now
we know when we use say digital programs
we use them in a device we take out the
phone we look at the screen and we see
something there changing reality around
us that sounds a bit weird right yeah
but it opens so much possibilities it's
a bit different than what people maybe
experience right now but I see that as
an opportunity because this could change
reality in a way that will make it
better for me I could be a superhuman
and I could understand what's happening
not next to me with a flick of finger I
can be from this meeting to my
workstation and there's opportunities
that are beyond what we know in our
physical world we can reach things that
we cannot do we can enable things that
we cannot do even for people that has
limitation in a physical world it might
be an opportunity to level the playing
field interesting we looked at ways that
it could affect conversation between
people because you suddenly have a lot
of information all the time with you and
it doesn't have that social effects of
getting the phone out while talking and
looking and suddenly you can do a lot of
for example we find out that we can help
introverts to have better conversations
great application for the software field
well I want to come back to that and
come back to it heavy a little bit later
in the podcast but even with what you've
talked about right now 25 years ago I
did not have the smartphone that I could
find out anything I wanted to anytime I
wanted to
anywhere I wanted to and so in a sense I
have a superpower already it just
happens to be in my pocket not in my
head right now
you're right in a sense that when we got
the internet we immediately sort of
upgrade our ability to know information
the augmented virtual space here is
about getting that information
without any visible device when you need
it we're looking at a different way that
it can change life of people whether it
is working obviously and how we can make
things more efficient this way to how we
can play to how we can communicate an
interface because one thing that you can
see today is that all those screens
around us basically reduce communication
between people you can see a family
sitting around the table and each one is
looking at its own phone what if the
information was around them so at least
their line of sight will include other
people and what if the system it can
show you private information but it will
incorporate that other person in a way
that you might still keep being merged
but unable to communicate with other
people you got your start in computer
vision and you are a bit of a serial
entrepreneur before you got your PhD yes
tell us about some other projects you
worked on back in the day and then talk
about the importance of timing
especially as it pertains to the little
failures that eventually lead to big
successes yeah I had several startups
even before during my PhD and it's fun
you could do things which are tolling
you and be able to show that to the
world and enjoy the impact that you see
around it like we did drawing
application which includes also free D
manipulation way before Photoshop or we
did a game engine that includes a
simulation of ray tracing and that was
in 94 my enjoyment was when we did
things which were really new and pushing
the envelope and that was maybe
different than what's needed from the
business point of view yeah at some
point I decided okay let's go all the
way for a novela T and I joined
Microsoft Research I want you to drill
in on this idea of timing because when
we talked before you mentioned that
you were kind of on point but too early
in the game and even you mentioned a
street view camera yeah prior to
Google's so that's actually was after I
joined Microsoft but you're right I mean
if I look at my startups they could have
been much more successful if there were
a few years later it's true for many
things that you try to push in and you
have to understand that the fact that
you have a prototype working might still
have a long way to get into the product
so for example we actually did a project
where we mapped to cities San Francisco
and Seattle and again this one actually
wasn't that early but it still was a
year and a half before the first
commercial one so just speculating here
what do you think then contributes to
the world not being ready for your great
idea well it's not that the world is not
ready but basically in general I know
you talked with Bill Buxton in the past
and he has this term of the long nose of
innovation where we see different new
technologies that came out and many
times you see 20 years before they
actually reach maturity yeah
[Music]
you framed AR and VR as a revolution
mm-hmm if we look at this through the
lens of other revolutions why do you
think AR and VR qualify as revolutionary
okay let me explain that and I can come
out with different directions so what's
the difference between what they enable
or what I expect them to do and what we
had before it's not about oh I can put
on a headset and now I'm immerse in a
game which is all around me no that's
not the revolution I mean it's nice and
cool yeah but there's several things
that I think are major difference which
actually most of them don't yet see in
the application in VR today or AR for
that matter the first one coming from
technology is suppose I right now want
to write an ARV our application how do I
do that right now what people do is very
much like they did then say writing a
game for Xbox I design a game I develop
the game test it clear all the bugs and
so on and now once I have it I ship it
as a product and everybody has to do
exactly what I did basically making sure
that whatever is the platform that they
used to run it is exactly as the
platform that I used to do so it's
standardized yes and you see that on
every software now what I see as an AR
VR is the fact that the software came
out of the computer and now live in our
environment so it's open up sort of a
Pandora Box how do I write such a
software because it should run
differently on different people so we
set that as a goal and we started
working on that almost ten years ago and
trying to see how can we make sure that
software will be on one hand similar for
everybody the same playability the same
story the same task that you need to do
and on the other hand be dependent on
how is it a rumor
aren't you out there other people what a
killer in what time of day it is and so
on so that's a huge technical challenge
it is so that's a technical side of it
yes and it's dependent on all the
sensors that are mapping my environment
and so it's personalized for me so it
has basically two elements one is an
element of understanding what's the
world mm-hmm so understanding what's out
there
what are dangers what are opportunities
that we can use that's one thing and on
the other hand understanding what is the
applications that we try to do let's say
I want to tell a story so a story will
have these free chapters that I need to
visit so I need to first visit chapter 1
chapter 2 and chapter 3 I need to put
them somewhere in your environment and
so this analysis of the environment on
one side and this breakup of the
narrative that I need to give you on the
other side and then matching between
them all right so this is a complete
shift from how people have written
software and what inputs they've used to
write this write the use of VR and AR
has been described as sporadic and
episodic yes why is that the case right
now and what will it take do you think
in terms of progress in these
technologies to move us from sporadic
and episodic to a more pervasive
adoption yes eventually what we want is
I want that they find coming in the
morning I will be able to control my
workspace regardless of how it looks
like whether I'm sitting in a bus or
that I have small office with no windows
I want to be able to do whatever I want
I'm not a touch typist I want as I type
on word that I will see my fingers just
beneath the line as I type and not where
they really are on the table I want to
be able to reach and
something which is really far for me I
want to right now jump to a conversation
we had last week and suddenly I'm in
that meeting room and a whiteboard has
the writing as we left it last week and
again I didn't drive to do that I want
to visit someone in a different site and
be able to walk with him in the site but
I'm still in my building you know those
people that walk around talking to the
air because they have a bluetooth
earpiece think of someone that walk
around the pavement but now he's also
wearing glasses and he's talking and he
actually is walking right now in a
different continent all these are
possible however if you look at what's
happening today yeah is there's several
imitation one is hardware limitation the
headset are still not that good heavy
limited on battery power connected to
big computers and tracking up till a few
years ago was limited to a room and
nowadays they have inside out cameras
that enables you basically to walk
around but even more fundamental is the
applications so this has to
fundamentally be changed to be more
flexible and again that's the direction
that we try to push when we talked about
the revolutionary nature of AR and VR
you talked about the technological
challenges and I know that there's
another angle to this which is the
social challenges right so talk about
that unpack what the challenge is there
and what we need to be thinking of you
okay so let me first say I mostly see
things an opportunity right I see an
opportunity to generate reality which is
not limited to the physical law that
reality by - nowadays all our life we're
in the cage of our body we see things
from our point of view we can go
wherever our body can get us and what
our senses can do and sadly we could see
things from
one else point of view we could extend
our senses let's say right now I'm in a
car and is a traffic jam what if my
point of view could jump from driver to
driver up until the point of trouble and
I see what's happening there what if I
could reach wherever I want without any
effort and as much as it's life-changing
for me it could be even more
life-changing for people that currently
has limitations in a non-physical world
then there's less importance of what my
physical ability is and it could be
leveling Plainfield interesting for
people not just physical as I said it
could also help people just by guiding
them in the moment to do things so just
a lot of potentials for example we did
the work in the past that was trying to
see if augmentation in augmented reality
can help people generate better
connections suppose I'm sitting in the
train and there's someone next to me and
we start talking and we have our means
of finding out if there's any connection
do you know this where did you learn
where do you live and so on and
sometimes we end up the conversation and
nothing happened and sometimes we just
fall on some commonality between us and
this conversation starts flowing really
fast and wouldn't be nice if I could
start the conversation this way so we
did experiment like that we gave people
that never met and we asked them what do
you want people to know about you what
is things that you want to talk about
what are things that you don't want to
talk about and then when they met we try
to enhance the conversation we want to
see several things we want to see if
people will be annoyed by the fact that
they are getting things while they need
to talk right and would the other person
be annoyed by the fact that I'm reading
something while he's talking and again
we want to see if this will enable the
conversation will it flow better would
you look for subjects would you use what
we did what you
so interesting enough first we're very
blind for what the other person is doing
and we are very bad discovering if the
other person have a whisper in his ear
of things to do second it depends on
people there's people that are great
talker and they don't need any help
and those people aid in to use our
system and be fought that this was sort
of what am I in the children garden why
are you good while other people that are
not that fortunate actually use this
anytime so what I'm hearing is
individual preference yeah on how you
like to interact with people what you
want people to know and where you like
to focus your reality
when we talked about the science of
doing AR and VR you mentioned three
areas that are important to get it right
we've talked a little bit about it but I
want you to drill in on what they are
and why they're super important okay so
the first one I don't really need even
to dive too deep in that is safety
obviously right now we are changing how
people perceive reality but at the end
of the day they live in reality and
reality can come back and bite them so
yes so they need to be aware if there is
any object that they might collide or
might fall and sometimes they're not
aware even if they don't have any device
so first you want to make people safe
and second now you have a story that you
need to give it yeah and I'm saying
story it could be a game it could be an
application just as well and you want
that this information that you gave
about the world will not break that
story so for example if I'm in a
spaceship and say my mother comes in
with the plate with cookies to give me
why I'm playing VR then she may appear
as a floating robot that comes in and
say there's nourishment and that cookies
will appear somewhere on a desk in the
spaceship will it be her voice or will
it be a robot voice that's a good
question right it could be a different
voice but at
when the voices associate with something
you see you tend to act so that's that
sort of mixed reality or mom cookies but
it's a robot right so we want to keep
the experience untouched by the fact
that the whole world is trying to
interfere with it okay so that's sort of
safety and math and reality - augmented
reality or virtual reality and what's
the third one a third one is privacy we
want to be able to give a lot of options
but on the other hand keep all
information at your place
[Music]
well if I let my imagination run I can
see how AR and VR could in essence
democratize our lives by extending
expanding and equalizing everyone's
experience with reality you know sitting
in coach class and maybe thinking its
first class hey I have more virtual leg
room even if my legs are still blocked
and also that your older car could see
it or like a fancy car tell us some
other areas where the concept of
resources and abilities might be
equalized by virtual and augmented
reality becoming a part of our lives
okay suddenly we got freedom we
disconnected ourselves from reality so
what can we gain as a result on the
other hand we don't want to totally
disconnect reality we want to be a
contributing citizen and be able to work
and interact with people and so on so
what we say is what if we could filter
out the reality so things which are
boring could become more interesting or
enlightening and so on we have a paper
right now called Dreamwalker I walk
every day for my home to work and it's
the same path basically and instead of
doing that path what if I could say walk
in Manhattan while I do that so again
safety first but then we can actually
generate a new environment around us or
maybe I'm doing a routine job I need to
bring parcel to some office and here we
can transfer you to maybe a fantasy
world where I'm running up with the
chalice up the heel fighting dragons and
getting it to the castle I mean there's
different opportunities that's not the
direction that currently we working
we're working more on getting people to
be more
in reality but still having more content
but it's a possibility how does this
play out in the ability world I know you
have some research and some papers in
this area yes
so one disability that we're trying to
look at is maybe the farthest away that
you would associate with virtual
augmented reality and that is a problem
with vision hmm because associated
virtual have you with such a visual
language what if blind person use it
yeah
so there's several reasons for that
let's talk first about low vision low
vision is some limitation with your
vision that cannot be fixed with glasses
there could be people that have limited
field of view or sensitivity to light or
low contrast or maybe blurry yeah and so
on now there's several opportunities
here when you look at applications that
come out for a virtuality there many
times just do F things with a lot of
atmosphere a lot of small details and
maybe dark in the environments and so on
and we wanted to make that reachable for
vision so we can use the fact that this
is a world that we know a lot about so
we can apply filters that will make
things look clear mark where objects
beginning and mark what could be grass
able and when we try that with a set of
people that had low vision problem we
can see how it's improved their ability
to do that now if you go even further
for people that are totally blind yes
they cannot see that display but they
can hear what's around them we can even
sense things such as virtual sensing of
a cane yeah that hits an object that did
not exist there and as a result they
know that there is an object and they
navigate a virtual and when you talk
about the increasing quality of our
virtual senses mostly we're talking
about vision in here
the touch has remained more elusive in
this arena so tell us why from a
technical perspective touch has been so
difficult to simulate and then talk
about the progress you're making in
haptics and some of the hot papers and
projects you're working on so first how
did I got to touch because as I say we
started with augmented reality and the
fact that applications will look
different in different environments
because we actually see the environment
now with virtual reality I just put
myself into a virtual world I no longer
see my environment around here what do I
care about the fact that your
environment is different than someone
else environment right and the answer to
that is mostly touch I can walk straight
forward and in your environment I will
be able to do five steps in someone else
environment after two steps I hit a wall
so I need to take that into account and
this means both how to avoid things I
don't want to touch in the environment
as well as how can I touch things which
are not there right so if I right now go
into current application I see very nice
graphics of virtual worlds around me and
I hear 3d audio around I can hear the
birds coming from the right and then I
reach my hand to touch the bird and
nothing there so we wanted to give the
sense of touch now this is hard and you
can see people working on things such as
exoskeleton we tie ourselves into some
robotic suit it's very expensive and
ever gets out of the lab and what we
wanted was something that we can see
coming to consumers so we said you know
what let's small the objects that we
actually are gonna hold so instead of
exoskeleton we went through controllers
because right now we also use controller
for Xbox and people that use VR right
now have two controllers to both track
the hands as well as some buttons to
oppress what if those controls crews
change their shape and be representative
for object
we grab and we had a whole set of
different devices it enables you to grab
objects of different sizes feel that
they're rigid or maybe compliant I could
press them and they will inflate back
when I release the pressure maybe I can
connect the two controllers in a way
that one time they can be rigid as if I
hold a box in my hand and I cannot bring
the two hands closer and then within a
second the two hands are free and can
move as they want so we have a whole
research direction that try to see what
can we do more and more in a way that
will be simple and cheap and robust so
people can put that into products and on
the other hand very realistic as much as
possible for the users we believe in
people using it in real environments so
we invite has objects for example if I
need to touch a virtual wall maybe
there's some wall around that I can
actually touch the problem that wall is
not where my virtual world is so if I
can fool you
since you don't see your real hands we
could bring your hand your real hand to
the real wall while you see your virtual
hand touching the virtual wall and that
timed experience will convince you that
virtual world is real and we did the
several works on that which we call
haptic retargeting which tries to as
much as possible use what's around you
as a mean for haptic sensations
[Music]
of all the research going on at MSR yes
AR and VR may provide the most Hollywood
ready script for a dystopian sci-fi
movie if I may say so as we've just said
the goal of your technology is to fool
me
with digital trompe l'oeil as it were
and empower me to believe I'm superhuman
yes somewhere on the spectrum of reality
virtual reality augmented reality
someplace in there while I maintain a
grasp of real reality because that's
important for me not to kill myself or
injure myself what could possibly go
wrong so despite the fact that you say
you want me to believe but you don't
want me to believe too much right is
there anything about this that keeps you
up at night so so there's several things
that we thinking of and I must say that
most of them are not unique to AR and VR
in this sense first how do I trust what
the system gives me right how do I trust
what I read on social network how do I
trust what I read in a paper in some
sense AR VR is easier because they deal
with the world just around me so hanging
off the headset will reveal me the real
world a me no matter how much I try to
fool you so we're very limited on what
we can actually convince you on the
other hand I will add the opposite
problem we don't want you to believe us
too much what do you mean by that is we
totally trust the technology right we
shouldn't technology even if all our
input is correct it might not be a full
input and their noises and there's
things that it doesn't know so if I for
example have a machine that tells me
here's a straight line and put the nails
along the straight line I should always
have in back of my mind maybe it's not a
straight line
and that's another thing that we try to
do so people will not be just totally
passive totally trusting the system how
are you doing that several ways that you
can do that one is you could involve the
person in the decision-making look
around tell me and things like that and
also use a language like I think you
should put the nail there what do you
say even with the language you can use
things that will generate some kind of
inner retrospective throwing the
liability on you so you will wake up and
say oh now I need to really understand
what's happening you know it's something
that you said earlier I just wanted to
bring out because I was just in Florida
and we wanted to go see some alligators
yes and the Gators are mating and moving
around in March April May and not in the
middle of the summer because guess why
it's too hot of her all underwater so we
went out for this ride and saw you know
the nose of one alligator what if I had
a virtual reality set of glasses and I
could go Gator watching in the wrong
season I have the photo of what if I say
go to from pay with my wife and I put on
a headset which sounds ridiculous I'm
already there
why do I need to put a headset right or
if I put a headset why did I even bother
coming to compare by the air wear but
the thing is it's the feeling that I
have right now off the air flowing the
smell of the food the people around me
but the people around me instead of
being tourists will wearing togas and
the cars around will be chariots and the
buildings will be full and my wife will
be there next to me and whenever I want
I switch to a full reality I totally see
that because having been to Pompeii
recently it would be I'm looking at the
ruins and what if the world were built
in front of me as it was run I could go
back and forth right even experience the
volcano eruption right
yeah maybe not that all right let's move
on you said we should do a series I
think you're right you're an interesting
guy Hale in a lot of ways tell us your
story
what got you into a life of high-tech
invention and how did you ultimately end
up in a life of research at MSR I would
say I started very early with computers
and I'm very visual in my nature I like
to draw actually did comics and book
covers and things like that so that's
moved me to graphics tend to computer
vision and understanding what's around
and in some sense VR and AR also include
another love that I have which is
interaction so suddenly it's not just
nice graphics we actually inside them
and that opens a lot of dreams of what
can you do what can you change that you
didn't have before would that be good
would that be confusing I started at the
beginning saying that we're sort of
living in the cage of our body what if I
could have seen from a different point
of view what if I could look for the
back if someone is coming what if I can
look behind the corner to see if someone
is running and I'm about to collide
would I find it confusing probably
because I never experienced looking for
a different point of view maybe I
learned to enjoy that and use more
alright so how did you end up at MSR so
after several startups I thought that
maybe the best thing is to go for
research and try to think ahead for the
world and when I thought of research
Microsoft Research was a shining diamond
that I immediately thought about it has
so many great names that I knew that
were working there like Andy Wilson or
Bill Paxton or can Inc Lee and when I
joined in I actually saw how great it is
that you have collaborators that you can
do and all the works I'm talking about
is basically a collaborative would mean
people like margins
this Franco and Mike Sinclair is our
hardware genius or Christian holes and
many others and of course a lot of
amazing interns that coming in and work
on it so I contact Harry show it was the
head of vision in the Microsoft lab in
Beijing and I moved over there really
yeah so I I've been 40 years in the
Microsoft research in Beijing and then
there was a new group that was forming
at Microsoft called virtual earth yeah
and I was lucky enough to be part of
that group and I moved to Redmond
after six years dare I felt like that
work that we did was amazing but the way
people experienced it was on a 2d screen
it was obvious that the next step should
be immersive I love that I'm waiting I'm
waiting well as we close I'd like you to
give us a vision of the future from your
perspective so if as you suggest we're
on the cusp of a revolution what's next
how will you along with the emerging
researchers get us to the next level in
AR and VR and what does the world look
like if you're wildly successful oh good
question and probably a smart person
should not talk about the future but in
general I see a lot of opportunity we
are changing the signal that we send to
our senses which is the way that we are
experiencing the world around us our
life I'm not sure we still understand
everything in this field and so there's
a lot of opportunities both on learning
what's happening around us so we can
better represent that and answer that
there's an effort on how to understand
what people want with as little
information as possible
when I use augmented reality the most
common mode is nothing right now most of
the time I don't want any information in
my field of view I like reality but
whenever I need it I want it so we do
things that I call contracts with the
system for example if I take a look at
the phone or the watch it has a lot of
social implication you will say oh he
might need to run somewhere we might
find me boring right but what if I will
just gaze and I see in the corner of the
walls and the ceiling what time is it
and how much time I have till my next
appointment you will not know about that
and I don't see that all the time only
when I do this gesture that the system
know so the more we know about the user
the more we just you know fit his wishes
or her and that's a great challenge as
well as how we can use the fact that
we're not limited where the distances
physical limitation and so on to maybe
do better communication better work
so it sounds really multidisciplinary
what you're talking about so there's all
kinds of places for a variety of kinds
of researchers to be engaging in this
work yes maybe it's not even seen like
that right now but I think it's a
exciting world at coming in when we only
see the tip of the iceberg and it's a
virtual iceberg earth is a hello effect
thank you so much for joining us today
thank you
it was fun
to learn more about dr. al Ofek and the
latest and augmented and virtual reality
research visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]